العودة إلى الوطن وإطلاق سراح
أسرى الحرب الأوكرانيين السابقين هؤلاء الذين احتجزتهم
القوات الروسية في السابق يتم الترحيب بهم من قبل الأصدقاء
والزملاء في حرية كييف في الوقت الحالي
هي سحب سيجارة تمشي على
أرض الوطن حتى لو كان ذلك يعني استخدام
عكازات
أكياس من الطعام يتم تسليمها إلى  أكثر
من 80 أسيرًا أوكرانيًا سابقًا تم إطلاق سراحهم
في تبادل سجناء مع روسيا ، إنها
وجبة مرحب بها ولحظة
للتخلص من الضغط والتفكير في
الإشاعات التي ترددت عن الإساءة الجسدية والعقلية
التي تعرضوا لها في الحجز
الروسي ، يقول أحد الأسرى يدعى جليب إنه تم القبض عليه
لمدة شهر تقريبًا  قبل إجلاء
المدنيين ، تعرض للضرب من قبل
الجنود
الروس ، وضربوني على وجهي بأعقاب مدافع رشاشة وركلوني ، كما تعرضت أسناني الأمامية للكسر أيضًا ، وكانت داشا في نفس الوحدة
التي قصفتها القوات الروسية التي قالوا
إنها حاولت كسرها.
جعلهم يصرخون المجد لروسيا
وحلقوا رؤوسهم
لإخبارهم أن ذلك كان لأغراض النظافة
ربما كانوا يحاولون تحطيم
أرواحنا بطريقة ما
لقد كانت صدمة
ولكن بعد ذلك نحن فتيات قويات كما تعلم ،
يقول ديميترو إن الجنود الروس اختطفوه
في ماريو بول وتعرض
للضرب يوميًا أثناء أسره ،
إنها محنة وسيستغرق الأمر وقتًا
للشفاء عقليًا وجسديًا على الرغم
من أن الكثيرين يقولون إنهم يريدون  بالعودة إلى
وحداتهم ومواصلة القتال ،
لكن قبل ذلك يظهر لنا جليب قصاصة من
الورق بما يقول إنها أرقام هواتف
أحباء السجناء الذين ما زالوا
أسرى من قبل الروس
، يقول إنه سيخبر العائلات أنهم
ما زالوا على قيد الحياة  لا نفقد الأمل